op
le spectacle se rapproche du paradis lorsque vous
lève la tête et enlève ton chapeau
ma main est petite au fond de la tienne
cœur un spectacle quand il veut descendre et le fait
une pente de spectacle quand vous voulez grandir et
tourner la corde
en juin
suit sous le banc le sol du
planète et troisième étage
la salle d'exposition où la vue atteint tous et
n'importe quel chemin arrive
montrer quand vous voulez supposer que vous vous cachez dans un
trou dans le sol meme sac pour en avoir un
tremblement de terre et le sol quand tes pieds s'enfuient
tout demande la gravité
alors nous ne serons qu'à un pied du sol
de la ville
le sol quand il s'enfuit qu'hôtels tous
demande la gravité
alors reste et pas seulement
sao paulo depuis le sol de la ville
le sol
max et max et lenny